all right so here's the deal
my girlfriend got covered we have no
idea how and somehow i didn't get it and
we have no idea how so i've been waiting
to tell this story
because i really wanted to be sure i
didn't get it and i wanted to be able to
tell you the the full story with some
definition
um so this this now goes back a period
of time but i'm going to lay it out for
you the the way that uh that that it all
is
um
let's call it we'll i'll just use day
numbers okay day one
she wakes up with a sore throat
we say uh oh let's see what's going on
we both take rapid tests and are both
negative
and uh we just hang out at home for the
remainder of that day by the end of the
day she's feeling fine
wakes up on day two says my symptoms are
gone
uh had a sore throat it's gone i'm
feeling fine on day two
end of day two she says i think i'm
still feeling fine but i just i don't
know i've got i'm just really weirdly
tired i don't know a little bit of a
headache okay
we go to day three wakes up she says my
sore throat is back
i'm feeling worse
uh i've got a headache let's go and
actually get
pcrs
uh go get pcr tests told you know it's
gonna be 24 to 48 hours before you get
the result later on day three she
develops a fever
uh so now we've got sore throat um and
fever
and a little bit of headache i feel fine
uh we're waiting on the pcr results but
she's got fever we go to day four day
four still has fever using tylenol to
manage it i still feel fine
now at this point we're assuming this
this real this actually could be covered
maybe the rapid test on day one was just
too early day four we get the pcr back
and it says negative everybody's still
negative now that was taken on day three
what would be considered day three of
symptoms
you know day two the symptoms went away
but
it's probably day three of symptoms pcr
is still negative
day four still has a fever fever starts
climbing 101 102
i still feel fine because she has the
negative pcr
i'm thinking well this is something else
we don't really have to worry we're
sharing a thermometer we're sharing food
we are you know i i
drove her in the car
to get the pcr tests we're
sleeping in the same bed it's okay day
four
uh fever is still there
day four at night
the fever
seems to go away
day five
she wakes up i still feel fine she wakes
up and she says my fever's gone
i'm less
feeling like i'm sick
my throat is about 50 percent better
maybe it's going away all right fair
enough
but then on day five she develops a
cough and it's it's not a good cough
this is the car it's what would be
called in the industry a productive
cough it's a bad cough
i still feel fine other than at this
point i'm having what i would do some
people call it a phantom
uh
a phantom headache and sore throat
some people would call it a jewish
neuroticism headache and sore throat
some some of you will understand what
that means
but i don't i don't really have symptoms
but i'm kind of like do i feel something
do i feel something so so now we're on
day five and because
we you know still getting negative covet
tests negative pcr negative negative
negative the sore throat she says could
this be strep could this be flu
fever fever's gone sore throat
that productive cough is here so we say
well we we need to get a flu test and we
need to get a strep test i'm still
feeling fine we're not isolating we're
in the car driving to get the strep and
flu etc etc
she gets tested for everything day five
at night
gets a call back and they did another
pcr just to be sure you know they test
for rsv other viruses flu strap etc
they say uh ma'am
you're negative for everything
except covid you have covit and she says
really i had
you know multiple negative rapids
negative pcr
uh et cetera et cetera no it's
definitely covid and you should be uh
she says do i do i need to isolate from
my partner my boyfriend we live together
and the doctor says yeah you you really
should
um
so at that point i'm just kind of
thinking
if i didn't get it yet
i'm not gonna get it right but day five
you can still be contagious even though
she's had 24 hours without a fever and
this is where it kind of gets to these
mixed messages we have the new cdc
guidance and the old cdc guidance if
you're without fever for 24 hours and
it's been five days in theory you're all
good but are you really do we know what
about omicron
all this different stuff
so
we start isolating and we isolate for
three days
sleep in separate rooms and you know
wear masks in the house when we pass
each other i really don't want to get
this thing and okay i had five days of
exposure day after day after day sharing
food sharing thermometer sharing ever
but we'll just isolate for the for for
the two three additional days at that
point you know she gets to day nine
and still has the nagging cough but is
otherwise mostly better
and at that point i say
i think i think i beat it i think with
the three doses
clearly i was exposed i was exposed in
the two days before she was symptom in
theory i was exposed on day minus one
and zero because that's when you're
believed to be most contagious and i was
exposed on days one two and three when
you're believed to be most contagious
and i was exposed on days four and five
during which your in general believed to
be lescon i just didn't get it now could
i have had
could i have had an asymptomatic case
yes one that was both asymptomatic and
was negative on uh rapid and pcr tests
now you might say well did you do
subsequent pcr tests i did
on day seven
we both did additional pcr testing she
was still positive
i was still negative
on day nine
we both did rapid tests she was uh we we
were both negative by that point in time
um so i don't know i don't have an
explanation you know it it's
i don't know that we will ever really
get an answer other than maybe it's as
simple as the vaccine worked the vaccine
which when you have three doses even
against omicron believe to be
75 effective against symptomatic disease
i mean this this was not passing
exposure that i had i think is the point
i'm trying to make we were in the car
driving back and forth from testing into
the hospital
or the urgent care whatever
the different different places to get
pcrs um
and we were you know in the same room
and sharing food
i was clearly exposed
and
apparently i had the
you know the neutralizing antibodies
were activated
and i somehow ended up not not getting
sick you know you hear about people
across the hall from someone in a hotel
isolating
one person has covered
it you know nicholas kristakis told us
about the story the person across the
hall gets it it can be that contagious
i feel like i dodged a bullet somehow uh
five days of of constant exposure really
seven days if you include the two days
prior to syndrome seven straight days of
full exposure
uh and and i didn't get it unfortunately
because we both uh work from home it
didn't create any kind of disruption in
terms of work or anything like that but
that's my story and you now know
everything i know and the reason i kept
waiting to tell the story was in my head
i was like okay what if i tell the story
now about how i didn't get it and then
somehow like she's still contagious on
day 14
and then it incubates for five days and
i end up with it on day 19. you know
these on on the edges of the bell curve
scenarios it's now been long enough it's
been you know three weeks that i'm
feeling pretty good that if i were to
get it now it wouldn't be from that now
where did she get it we have no idea
first of all we
we basically both have been doing the
exact same stuff we go to the same
places we don't do any indoor dining
we're not going to the movie theater
we're not going to sporting events we're
not doing any of that stuff um we we
didn't
we didn't really have any indoor
unmasked contact with anybody other than
a car ride with my brother who also
hadn't done anything
had no symptoms had no positive tests
before after during is it possible that
this is so contagious
that some of those other means could
could potentially give you the virus
there was an instance where
when we were outdoor dining she went in
to the restroom with a mask on could
there have been a surface thing there
um
grocery store i mean
it's we really have no idea and
presumably not only did i not get it
from her but we were both exposed to
wherever she got it
and i i still didn't get it so i don't
know folks i don't know but it is uh
very very wild times and that's the full
story
uh as i understand it right now